hmm our live we can hear it we're live
welcome everybody to the fifth episode
of rent cafe this is why I can't believe
it's our fifth episode already we're
here with Mackel not Brynn from brands
fandoms and Briggs from all-day anime
and how do you guys feel about episode 5
I think Mac you've been here for every
episode Brent you've been here forever
it's over except one and Briggs you've
been for like three I play so how do you
guys feel about this are you excited
you should be the best one yet the next
one is always the best one that's how it
works
Mac how do you feel bro oh that's me
yeah I feel good I feel good
I've been waiting for this o week all
week I've been waiting for it for so
long I'm excited it's good yes my life
has been prepared for this moment right
here I've been training in a way right
to get to this did you get a
notification for this dream because I
did not huh yeah I got one sometimes you
got a notification I love you don't so
that's the that's what YouTube is today
but yeah I want to say what's up to
creep ln1 master I see you guys in the
chat elf and silver armors already been
here a while we'll be already been
chatting and ranting together vector
Maximus is here who else is here I think
we got some other peeps in here we got
Mackel nage Makela Mackel not here's the
worst you should is a disturber of the
yeah so in this episode guys we're gonna
be done with all the diverse and
different many genres of anime and all
that kind of stuff regarding that which
are favourite genres which are least
favourite genres
what is the advantage of having all
these different genres is there some
disadvantages and other stuff whatever
you guys want to talk about the chat
will cover that too here we definitely
look at the chat right Briggs yeah I do
that
I was horrible yesterday oh my god yeah
we had an improv impromptu stream with
Briggs an all-day anime and a little fun
then that was a real rant we were just
all right like you guys should have seen
that we were arguing about Amelia versus
ramp the whole time it was supposed to
be winter 2017 like what we're looking
forward to the first 15 minutes and last
10 minutes of the stream where Amelia
versus REM and I mean it's it's
obviously no contest who's yeah team
Amelia right team Amelia forever that's
why I like you Anna Mac cuz you're a
comedian and you make funny jokes like
that it's that's good
no but seriously though we're gonna
we're gonna get into this guys no make a
video on reason zero where I will prove
definitively just like I proved that
Lelouch was alive I will prove that
Amelia is best girl so stay tuned for
that but in the meantime in the meantime
let's get into this whole genre thing
let me see my notes let me check my
notes these are real notes it's not just
blank pages and I'm not just trying to
look professional so because there are
many diverse genres and subgenres in
anime and in manga of course what are
your thoughts on this fact is this a
good thing is this a bad thing do you
like it do you love it do you think that
maybe there's too much diversity let's
go to bricks I think diversity is always
like awesome Anatomy and I feel like
they animate copies a lot of tropes and
like there's a lot of anime that are
very similar to others so without
diversity we would just get the same
thing and maybe when I started watching
anime I was very into one specific genre
but as I got more into it like I enjoy
watching everything now and I'm trying
to reply to Viktor Maximus and tell him
that devil is a part-timer is unreal yes
I actually enjoyed devil as a part-timer
I really liked that it was like it was
cool because it kind of flips it on its
head like it starts off as like a really
serious fantasy anime and it just turns
into this insane comedy and it's funny
because I saw one on a MV
I think it was a guy called maybe it was
warlocks and me I believe he did he did
a ambi where it made the anime look like
like the serious animate kind of like it
was spoofing it was funny because the
AMV makes it look so serious and with
like serious music and almost got
something looked cool but it's
definitely not what the anime actually
is but I thought yeah cool interesting
hilarious like slice-of-life fantasy a
comedy I really enjoy it and it's like
like I'm saying like diversity wise I
think devil is a part-timer is not a
typical anime I would be really into
like it's very slice of life just like
the main character is going about their
their jobs are like trying to make a
living like on earth rather than like
their fantasy world and like surviving
and stuff and just like comedic things
that happen like in the rumen or like at
work and it's not slice of life isn't
usually a drawn room into but for that
series it just works it's like series I
really enjoy yeah so it's what else do
you need in an anime really yes sure you
guys could see that by like three that
well the part-time or lifetime novels
there probably can't be nice
Ivan Ivan I'm really into the series
mm-hmm yeah so I wish they had more
episodes above the actual anime
personally yeah I really enjoyed it
it only had like 12 or 13 and then I had
to freaking by the light novels but
takes up my time on my subway trips yeah
it's uh me best tuned aray yep Loki if a
descender is another new er that is also
kind of best girl yeah there's some
classy assume there is you have you know
Haruhi tygon there's good Sooners
there's annoying soon there is but you
know you've got to give a shout-out to
taiga too hot okay - Emmy um Mac what
about you what about the diversity of
anime how much do you love it do you
have some issues with some of the genres
- let me know I mean I don't watch a
whole lot of edgy stuff but it's just
not my thing but then there's then again
there's good at you right but I think
it's I kind of agree with Briggs like
it's it's good
you can't have just like one genre you
can't just have you know only mecha
anime or only you know romance in and
they like I think it's I think it's good
like if you can have say something like
mecha romance or mecha or mecha edgy you
know something just you know to keep it
mixed up or something like that it's all
been done
has there been has there been a mecha
edgy though just just the robots if not
that needs to be a thing you're probably
five really good ideas for new anime we
got start pitching to Studios guys like
someone needs to learn Japanese because
we need to start pitching to these
studios I thought your pronunciation
yesterday I think you have to be the
first one to learn Japanese yeah III try
to pronounce the stuff that I know but
the stuff that I don't know I can't
think of so that's the problem and don't
get me started on reading but we had my
van Maru just rolled into the Chad
welcome Juan Maru and we have some good
discussions going on already a lot of
people are mentioning yo e especially
elf and we I will leave that to Mac as
the stream goes on undisputed king yeah
only a thing if you put it on my
gravestone and someone has to pay for it
so zero they need to have the selection
for the king but in Rand cafe there is
only one king
not in the world is only one kick about
yeah Britain let's go to you what your
thoughts on different genres in anime
and how much the diversity of those
genres well I know that when I first
started watching anime I definitely air
towards certain genres over others I
really did not get into probably any
Mecca or like action till later on in
the game I was focused on like the
comedy aspect and like kind of a
light-hearted slice of life stuff but I
like that there's diversity there should
be diverse
because it gives you options and when
they couldn't like we are talking about
when you mix different genres together
it makes cool things and interesting
things like sports and boy love what hey
but there are options right and that's
good for diversity and everyone will say
like I don't like this or like this is
way better than the other and like trash
talk each other cuz that's just
sometimes health community is but it's
good to have diversity I just definitely
appeals the different types of people or
eeeh like you said you like you really
you were really into slice of life and
that's like probably one of my least
favorite genres right like it's
everything appeals to different people
so they have to try to get everything
out there but then eventually you start
like expanding and realizing everything
has good series cuz like Mac said like I
don't like actually actually and slice
of life or to my like least favorite
genres but then there's no game no life
with it which is it actually and
shokugeki no souma which was in that
sheet and those are two of my favorite
series so kind of like counteracts the
fact I don't even like those genres yeah
it's interesting and I really find the
whole idea I and I had done in my notes
about crossing genres so different
genres coming together and I feel like
that is a big thing in anime and
sometimes it works well sometimes it
doesn't but like yeah mixing like for
example sci-fi and fantasy and sword art
online or mixing you know paranormal
with slice of life or old man's high
school romance then how do he and all
this different stuff I don't know if you
guys do you have some examples you can
think of a really good anime but their
cross multiple genres other than urea
nice well I always feel like action and
fantasy usually always go well together
or like Shonen and fantasy those kind of
things or go well generally speaking and
of course like romance and comedy
generally speaking our hand in hand or
like romance the slice of life yes sure
going from opposite spectrums I think
you're gonna have a harder time like
finding oh no actually I should say this
like a mecca edge eat like I don't know
if that actually exists out there but
I'm sure somewhere someone has pitched
the idea I mean like not with robots but
there's definitely been like mecha
series that are actually with people in
it I catch you guys but the people
mm-hmm I think it's honestly probably
hard to find things that don't overlap
yeah Jonathan
Essex is in the chat what's up bro how's
it going yeah do you do you guys have
any favorite kind of overlaps that you
can think of specifically like a really
good anime that you liked that's uh
crosses maybe weird Ron was like for
example like the devil is a part-timer
going from a dark fantasy with like
murdering and everything to like us you
know slice a life romantic-comedy
think school live was pretty good for
that i don't know if any of you guys
watch that but it and it totally tricks
you into thinking that it's one thing
like the entire first episode it's like
this is totally normal like high school
slice of life just really cutesy like
even though even the opening is super
like but then by the end right at the
end of the first episode you're like oh
the same thing i thought it was it all
it just turns into something totally
different but it can't it kind of keeps
the I guess more my way aspects of it
kind of throughout but still like I
don't want to spoil anything for you who
haven't seen it but still has the the
other stuff already did it pull a Madoka
Magica yes yeah and then episode three
comes along you're like what the [ __ ]
and I start getting dark and like takes
a completely different exactly it's that
but it does that right at the end of the
first episode when you won't expect it
you're like alright this is old man just
like it takes like two seconds to switch
everything it's crazy yeah that was one
that I was gonna mention I was like that
one's one that's like supposed to be all
these like keeps magic girl one and then
they're like murdering each other I'm
like around applause yes yes so that's
definitely a weird crossover but it
works it's definitely more violent than
cute now but that's okay that's what
they're going for
yeah and we're getting a lot of activity
that chad lou talks anime is here what's
up Lu he's giving us some suggestions he
says magical shopping arcade up in the
wash she touches basically every genre
it's great I've never actually seen that
but that does sound pretty interesting
magical shopping arcade oh soul adiga
what's up latina he says anime upper
we're at 2999 subs yes we are so we're
trying to push that 3000 baby we're
trying to push it live and turning the
screen we have our friend who writes in
Japanese what up Japanese writing friend
one day I will understand you and chat
with you and we'll have a good lunch ugh
we also have Aiden Bennet and we have
Mansoor Takeda so yeah lots of cool
people in the chat talking about some
cool things I was thinking what what's
another crossover anime did I really
thought was interesting like for example
I feel like there are some like toradora
would be just slice-of-life right yeah
wait what was your example of just
slice-of-life
toradora or toreador offered yeah took
me a second English folk okay wait I
want to put this to rest how are you
supposed to pronounce it Monsieur
Toronado on Terada rap all right I
thought oh I thought you're saying Jura
rubra
I thought you think Aurora covers a lot
of like different genres like it's like
supernatural and SCHIP well think it
starts off like high school like no and
it's crazy because it's high school
students the main character then it
involves like mafia and like demons and
sure I even know like that really had a
lot of different genres in it yeah der
are all for sure
interesting because it's a really
interesting setup and I really like or
would you guys say durarara okay but
fine moving on
but I really like the setup and the
characters they're like some of the
characters are really really cool and
interesting but down like the plot seems
to drag to me in that anime and it's
like almost they try to do too much
introduce too large or a cast and then
it kind of like it's like they don't
know where they're going with it and I
say this was Authority because our kata
from glass reflections have pretty much
the same thing in his review so then I
feel like I can just call on him if you
guys are like man you're wrong I'm just
like well that's your reference our kata
is a pretty recent youtuber and
reviewers I agree I still enjoyed it
because like you said it's very like I
guess character driven and I enjoyed a
lot of the characters but the plot drag
now I didn't like it I wasn't even there
for the plot sometimes I think I was
there for like she's really majima eyes
I like they had a lot of cool badass
characters in that series mm-hmm sorry I
I was just making a side comment Darrell
Rob went on too long yeah it was just
and just too many gaps like it was a
four or five year gap in between seasons
so I had to go back and really watch
everything in order to watch the new
season yeah we got just two exactly and
Jake will listen to chat what's up guys
and our Japanese friend says
Arica seven I understand that part so I
actually did or Eureka so I actually
didn't like Erika seven much because
again like but even worse than Aurora
it has a nice setup like I like the
whole world that they build it's very
interesting very cool characters like
that group of kind of outcasts that the
main characters Renton joins and I find
it really interesting set up and then
again the plot just drags like I feel
like I don't care about the plot it's
just too long it's disjointed so yeah I
just
that's another anime that I felt really
suffered from pacing issues I guess
pacing would be the word
that's a good word the right word to
like sorry go ahead
I was gonna change like the topic kind
of I was like talking to one of my
friend yesterday he was trying to find
like genres for a top-10 and he was
asking me what I think the most popular
genres are and I want to get your
opinions on that like what do you guys
think the most popular genre is or
Chandra's let's say probably itchy and
whatever Dragon Ball Z yes imagine both
oh my god so like shown in and actually
series I guess you're saying I said
Shonen as well I for sure there's a lot
of shown in May because they're just so
long-running generally speaking they're
pretty long-running so maybe that's why
it feels like there's it's pretty
popular cuz there there's always fans
for it right there's always gonna be the
people that are gonna be rooting for
yeah there's always that one guy who's
into one piece and he always tries to
get all his friends and rant conveyed to
watch one piece so you can talk about it
and he's right a hundred percent
true story
Lou talks anime says edgy plus Dragon
Ball Z equals kaiju you're not wrong
actually plus shown in equal shokugeki
no souma a good cross right there foo
doors to watch that I watched episode 1
I'm like wait no you need to get more
than what happens I know I know I
dropped it I dropped it up for the first
episode and eventually some when people
were like hype about it I'm like okay
I'll give more of a chance and it's
unreal cross 9 says that he loves one
piece so there's your boy bestie there's
your boy and Jake Lewis says that sports
and Mecca are his favorite genres so
yeah both cool genres when are we gonna
mix those two together like a sport that
can only be played with mecca's like
some kind of Mecca Quidditch like
they'll be a good anime right now any
diving for we're making that next anime
idea
yes so much good ideas got so many good
ideas only at the rent cafe by the way
earlier elephant silver armor was saying
before the stream started he was like
you guys never rant you just talk old
politely why don't you ever argue and I
told them well you should have been it
the old a anime stream yesterday cuz
that's all that's where the the ranting
happened rude
Toto told me to get out of my own stream
kicking you out of the stream it's my
stream Lu talks and says sports plus
matka is equals Gundam build fighters I
don't know what that is I've never heard
of that and then Jake Lewis said that
he'd think that there's a basketball and
mecca's mixed together can't remember
the name though I've never heard of it
but yeah the only an interesting thing
oh by the way by the way guys Donald the
Dead The Walking Dead + ecchi High
School of the Dead true true yes sure
that is what that is one of the I think
most blatant examples of like to be
honest that you wouldn't think would go
together and they just like splash it
together and they're like deal with this
more like you hope it would never get
put together and then I didn't go okay I
guess it's it's funny guy like I think
everyone knows it's like not that great
of a series but I still enjoyed it so
much
I've watched it in Japanese and in
English too compared which one I like
better I've watched like three or four
times high school today yeah yeah my
brother actually wrote an essay for
school about it like he was getting all
academic about and I was like yeah
that's why I watched it too I watched it
was pure fun seriously but it was really
enjoyable and that is I think one of the
strengths of anime because I feel like
you don't really in mainstream Western
media or Hollywood see that kind of like
crazy genre mixing like did you hear
about that manga what's it called
girls owned pond sir
I've heard of it but I haven't watched
it I just like girls and tanks girls in
tanks oh yes okay it's like a Japanese
title like what like German but yeah
like what like who thinks of that like
you're not gonna find like a like you
know popular Western series or something
that kind of blends such crazy things
together like Moy girls and tanks like
yeah so I think that's a strength number
one thing that I was thinking about is
also could like such so much diversity
be a weakness of anime because the thing
is that obviously we're moving more
towards many would argue financial sort
of orientation and of course mixtures of
genres they'll usually they'll have like
a niche following but not a huge
following so do you think that by
focusing on so much diversity and kind
of putting out putting energy and all
these different and finances and all
these different areas that what's going
to happen is that these small studios
are these like studios with that are be
more experimental might suffer because
they'll they won't be able to earn the
money they need and then as a result
only the mainstream studios are gonna
succeed which is going to lead to the
same kind of cookie cutter popular anime
being made again and again like we have
if you could argue in Hollywood we call
it with films and many are already
arguing that we're getting to that point
where it's all just like getting very
like you know mainstream you got your
harem you got your fantasy you got your
overpowered guy that everyone loves for
some reason you got your best girl right
so like a lot of people are going to
come very jaded and cynical about what
the anime industry is becoming already
so how do we preserve that diversity
then what do you guys think yeah
although to say I feel like that's
already happening like people like
what's called Studios are like very much
so going for like the sure thing what
they think is gonna sell based on what's
like sold previous seasons I got a few
guys notice like a pattern I think if
one show is popular like the hit show
this season the next season there's a
bunch of copycats cuz they know
people are just gonna view it and I feel
like that something like it has to be
financial because at the end the day
comes down to selling and making money
but also with a diversification thing it
could be a data here thing like what
could be the downfall diversification in
anime they could be like because you
said it's not happening so much in
westernized anime so it might be hard
for us to bring in more fans because
they're so niche and so like so many
different genres that don't appeal to
that many people yeah it's true that's
that's the thing like niche is great
because it brings diversity brings all
these different things but the problem
with it is that that's just what it is
it's niche so sometimes a niche series
or something will take off and it will
gain mainstream popularity but often it
will have like you know a narrow
following but it won't be able to kind
of move beyond that's why many anime
that I think are great end up only
having like 13 episodes right or like 10
episodes and then they never renew them
because it was just too different from
like the norm and the usual which is
exact cause I feel like a lot of these
and they have potential and yeah I don't
know I don't know it's it's a hard one
it's a hard one
so true though so many 13 episode series
we've been getting yeah for sure
unfortunately and then I gotta go out
and buy freaking light novels but I
don't mind supporting I just don't
prefer reading mm-hmm I feel like yeah I
feel like there will always be certain
genres that will be popular over others
cuz I think even if you're not an anime
person you don't something like attack
on Titan is like pretty big because it
up like it's crazy and it appeals to non
anime people too so I think industries
are like hey psychological like ooh kind
of gory and crazy that would be a good
show for not only anime people but for
all and made people and wits to do
stupid them they made what was it called
cabin Ares the iron fortress when they
could have just made another season of
on Titan but they're like no no we gotta
wait because we gotta save our money and
print money later on when we feel like
doing it yeah I don't get that either
I don't get that any they're like I
would rather have more seasons of
popular anime of their popular um it
just kind of continue that story if it's
a good story then have a bunch of
copycats
that's so obvious even if you look at
like the promotional imagery like just a
poster or something you're like wow I
know exactly what you're going for
exactly what you're copying like yep
the emember like once order our line
came around the next like even it's
still coming out to this day the amount
of like copycat like stuck in a MMORPG
is ridiculous
yeah they're like blue exorcist like the
promotional material to me looks very
much like sword art online um I feel
like I I could see the look but the
premise and everything is very different
no I know I know what I'm saying I think
they're trying to market it uh so if you
likes or Alive you're like this and that
you kind of try to draw you there but
like yeah yeah exactly they've been
they're both animated by a-1 picture so
they have a very similar look and there
I think they're Daffy trying to market
it to P like fans of soda online I agree
assassin gaming says can we please get a
remake for uh come and go come and go
kill and yes now that you asked me I
have that power so that's his Geass
imagine if you have the power your gears
powers to have any anime you want
created Oh what would be your first like
like your first season two that you
wanted season - or like continuation
Cowboy Bebop I shot you down last night
when you fed that actually I know but oh
I don't love to see it I'm happy with
how it ended
what about you guys if you had to have
another season of something or would you
have either high school the dead or just
I think of another one I'll let Brenda
side hmm
you don't know if the dawn or what was
it it blanked unka got no it Snow White
in the red hair I haven't hadn't seen
either of those shows
you have a unique taste Bryn I feel like
no one else would have mentioned those
snow what I didn't watch all of it was
the snow white with the red hair red
yeah okay I watched I was interested I
watch like the first three or four
episodes I'm like is this is cool and
then didn't want to do with every anime
and forgot about it and I feel yeah
I feel um vector says he would like to
see another episode of another season
isn't another season coming out
yeah next winter 2017 yeah dr. winters
2017 and blue exorcist is coming back I
learned that from all-day anime shelter
so like I was like two three weeks I
think
and Lu said something he said the
business model for anime distribution
Japan is hurting the industry more than
anything I think anime Studios should
have a role in production committees by
default instead of being commissioned I
agree because I think you told me that
actually Animax like they have like a
like a Sai preset wage that like they're
guaranteed for when they like when they
use the series but depending on how
popular it is if it's a really popular
series they don't actually get paid more
so like I don't know if I think you're
the one who told me that yeah like so if
it's like the guy who already had a
really popular series next time has a
second series then obviously can ask for
more because he's like I've proven my
model to your momentum is not successful
you can you have to give me more money
now but if you're making if you're a
small-time animator of making a you know
a manga creator getting on adaption for
the first time you will only get a
certain you know feed that they think is
reasonable and then it doesn't matter
how much it actually makes whether it's
1 million 100 million you're still going
to get just stick your feet yeah let you
go it so don't if it makes 200 million
and they might come back to you and say
hey you have another series for us and
then you could say ok but this time give
me more money but still like wait a time
did they create an anime that it airs
and then they might create another anime
it's much much too slow a process that
needs to be for sure I think there needs
to be some some kind of reform in the
industry in terms of encouraging
manga creators young new manga creators
to be able to get
to the industry encouraging new
animators because I really fear and we
talked about this last week in the
future anime Ren cafe but we talked
about how if we if the industry is so
hard to break into if being new in the
industry and you don't have a name for
yourself yet you can barely make ends
meet you have to work like 16-hour days
how are you going to you know how long
are you gonna keep trying before you
just try something else which I'm sick
of this like I it's my passion but I
need to pay the bills I'm just gonna be
an engineer via janitor or whatever so I
can pay the bills so that that is again
the danger of kind of pigeon holing
anime to that one model oh this is what
makes money that worth whether it's the
mo or whatever because that then we're
gonna be have a cookie cutter industry
and that's something that definitely
scares me because the reason that I love
anime is because it is different from
Western shows and animation culturally
different but also stylistically
different its unique like we said that
diversity you don't see it everywhere so
I'm like where you do see it like
someone like Quentin Tarantino or you
know the inception movies movie matrix
all of those were in many ways
influenced by anime yep right so the so
in fact anime has been influencing
Hollywood many of the unique movies that
we like and appreciate were influenced
by anime so it's like I really fear if
anime becomes just a cookie cutter
industry because no the bottom line then
yeah like we're all gonna become just
those nostalgic they're like man anime
used to be good and now it's crap yeah I
think me and you a tobacco or do a badge
Audra I still have hope well yeah I
don't watch like some stuff but I'm like
I'm still kind of in the past a little
bit yeah I mean to because I knew are
some stuff doing and you sometimes you
find like a gem like one punch man but I
just feel like overall if you look at
like newer series most of them are
mediocre not much of it like speaks to
me my killer killed in but that's
already 2012 now right so yeah I don't
know bran you watch a lot of
anywhere shows right like what do you
think yeah I like keeping up with the
newer things but there's a lot like
there's just it's just a lot right
there's a lot of content to watch and as
that is being produced so you do have
some good ones but you do have to kind
of see what does well so to speak
because killer kill is good you know
like there were some couple good ones
these past couple of years like one
punch man things like that but shows
that I find interesting might not gain
that popularity till later on because it
needs time for people to be like oh my
gosh have you heard about the show look
at this and so yeah I watch a lot of
newer shows but I do like going back and
watching some of the later ones because
they're good it's just in a different
way you know but there's still good
quality anime out there you just have to
find it yeah I'd be like it's seasoned a
lot I think there's a couple of gems
every season but overall is this a lot
of like there's a lot of anime and it
can't all be good and it really isn't
yeah I never the danger I like it has to
be about quality not quantity because if
you want quantity that you know why why
would you there's a lot of stuff going
on but if you don't if you don't if
you're producing these enemies just
chugging them out and not actually
spending time on they're not making him
mean anything they're going to be
forgotten in a year in two years
like how many Cowboy Bebop SAR being
produced today that we're gonna keep
remembering in 10 years and 20 years
right so that's that is the fear and
someone asked in the chat why would uh
well if Trump was an anime what's your
honor would his be would would he be and
I think it would be a mecha harem edgy
Trump the enemy yeah I would definitely
think of you that chief yeah like if you
like nice hair he likes to be strong and
you like so he likes women so you like
to grab things yes what things but
things or could be a warfare anime yeah
that you work Oh
but it has to have that she come on well
for sure give you an incentive to watch
the Trump animals because I got a lure
people in with all that Trump fan
service but they should make Trump look
like like a really like beautiful thin
pretty boy kind of like a Lelouch just
like just like just like to be out just
to be ironic just like yeah what are
some of the weirdest genres that you've
come across in Europe your most unique
or weird and kind of like creepy away
like I don't know like bond or something
I don't know bondage I don't know why
you kids watch what you young uns
whippersnappers they're watching
I'll watch me my Dragon Ball Z did you
man I don't know what you got I watched
the first two episodes of Digimon for
the first time ever like a day ago or
two days ago and it was it's pretty
great pretty great have any of you
dabbled in the world of Uri anime but
like not like you're a nice like actual
Yuri or yo I know admit your deepest
admit yeah I feel like those genres are
definitely like a niche kind of genres
like Eddie's kind of generalized it's
just a general category right but it's
like Yuri is a very very specific
targeted people they're targeting a
certain specific audience for those type
of shows I think I don't know that was
the question but that's definitely an
interesting every once in a while yeah
for sure everyone small you'll be
watching a series and like you don't
realize it's your your yaoi and halfway
through something happened there it's
like wow I can't think of the name I
can't remember the name I was watching
One series were like Episode seven mind
blown
it was no great Syrian like I continued
to watch I really enjoyed it I can't
remember freaking name a long time ago
but a blew my mind
one I'd forget what season it was but it
was how do you even explain it there
were like five minute episodes of it's
almost like boyfriend simulator and it's
like did you see I know what you're
talking about like you the viewer
talking to like your boyfriend or
whatever your boyfriend episodes my room
and like what am i watching right now
they're like five minute episodes and
there's like twelve of them and every
episode it's a different boyfriend and
that that weirded me out if anyone was
called but that's definitely oh now I'm
gonna look it up but it's like a
sleeping boyfriend no it's like a little
boy
yeah yes see okay we know we're talking
about yeah that's definitely a weird
genre like one of those weird things
that come out that's like what who is
watching this oh and another weird one
a banana but you know I want to look at
some bananas
okay that's your show right I don't know
who that's targeting this early but like
why I don't understand you
go ahead oh yeah bring you made a good
point about targeting right because yes
certain shows are probably because they
really target like Shonen or like those
people who like the Yowie like whoever
they are and so like yeah they target
them and then they make money because
these people are like active like you
know buyers they they have a community
where they're like yeah this is good
this is what we're watching and this is
what we're buying
however again it's pandering essentially
so then again it there's the threat of
it becoming very cookie cutter right
it's like okay well this is what they
want this is what they wanted last
season so let's just like dress it up a
bit and give it the same thing to them
again this season so whether it's the
ecchi crowd that you how he crowd is
there a URI crowd I don't even know yeah
for everything made yeah it's out there
I know it's a genre but like I don't I
don't see that much of it but yeah it's
oh yeah that also I even though those
are like targeting specific markets I
feel like that too can become very
repetitive very kind of does just keep
dishing on the same stuff because that's
what works yeah what's a unique or by
the way I think uh who was it in the
chat that mentioned I think it was Jake
Lewis who mentioned Cowboy Bebop clone
and any he listed a series Ivan's seen
that one but I wouldn't say it's a clone
but like a series the game yeah cowboy
bebop feel was gun sword or a gun X
sword I feel like a lot of people
haven't seen that but I actually watched
it recently and I really enjoyed it like
the main character kind of gets me gives
me like a spike line and in the end I've
been drawing the shoulder it's like
there's some fanswers but it's tasteful
and like yeah it's a cool like a sci-fi
it's actually a mecha western actually
that's a good example of a mix because
it takes place on like a planet that was
a prison planet created by like third
earthlings
but then it was abandoned and then so
they live in like a Wild West type world
but with mecca's so yeah like I like
Trigon without mecca's mm-hm yeah yeah
trial would be like a more Western
Western sci-fi master but becomes sci-fi
later like you realize later it's true
whereas this is like where I don't right
off the bat but yeah it was very dribble
on the yeah I like try got as well yeah
try gonna had a similar feel I guess to
like cowboy bebop ish more Black Lagoon
I would say both shows I would want more
of if I had the G ass power yeah my
problem is with Trigon it's just like he
takes Vash the Stampede he's a cool
character but he thinks this whole I'm
I'm not gonna kill anyone and I'm gonna
be really nice too far kind of thing
that he's like a he's like a gold coul
right in that sense and it's kind of its
kind of gifts childish in certain times
like you kind of feel like okay man well
this guy if you don't kill him he's
gonna kill like a bunch of other people
like you gotta kill him
you gotta kill when you watch a series
where the protagonist has these morals
that like he won't break no matter what
and you're just
like you're so stupid like I guess
what's the name amia or Shiro amia from
fate/zero
yeah like the fate franchise like you
guys like morals and like if you could
save someone you always want to save
everyone even the cost of his life when
sometimes it's like ridiculous oh you're
gonna die yeah and that gets gets gets
to me because like okay you can portray
that conflict in like one or two
episodes like okay he's conflicted but
then move on but like I don't like how
some of these anime they just like this
conflict keeps coming up so like like
Shinji in a Miguel Ian like he has he
was having the same conflict or ever
like your father doesn't love you Shinji
it happens it happens your dad just
doesn't like you man yeah he's a like
you should take comfort Shinji into five
your dad is a genuinely awful human
being so maybe it's a good thing he
doesn't like you like blonde buddy move
on any other interesting genres weird
genres unique genres that you like in
anime maybe some Connors do you think
are underrated historical I think I was
just gonna say that out of it yeah
there needs to be more historical
because there are it's it's a different
world like it's just a different period
of time depending on what period of time
they choose to do it so there's so many
options and just exploring the world
itself of whatever historical time
setting they choose it's really good
like they they need to get make more of
those yeah how are you enjoying Drifters
I like you what I think I remember using
you while you're watching it yeah I'm
watching it it's it's pretty bloody lots
of chopping heads chopped off from stuff
but no I think it's good I think it's
cool how they use different people of
different eras and bring them together a
lot of the time I'm like I don't really
know who this person is like their
historical significance of like what
they did actually in real life but I
like them that's pretty cool cuz like
find that cool as well because I'll
actually like go and research the person
kind like oh who's this person I did
that in fate/zero a lot like I learned
all about Gilgamesh yeah yeah like faith
faith series is interesting because they
include historical figures but they're
highly fictionalized yeah I go yeah
that's just an example of someone I
researched really had very mythology
based and stuff but just yeah it's it's
it's really cool yeah for sure and like
I I would definitely agree with
historical genre like samurai Champloo
was very cool it was like historical and
it was quite I think accurate
historically except they had hip-hop
music yeah like the introduced like hip
hop music and hip hop culture kind of to
the anime to the feel of the anime but
it was still a historical animal death
and old period so I thought that was
where you like interesting like it's
it's it's modern and its historical at
the same time but definitely I feel like
historical anime are underrated I feel
um mushishi was a good anime that's kind
of clearly taking place in like an older
time maybe 1800s or something it doesn't
really talk about specific historical
begins but events but it talks about the
full core the beliefs kind of of the
villagers and mountain villages seaside
villages things like that so I feel like
it's definitely based on like Japanese
the mythology and things of that and I
really liked mushishi a lot even though
there isn't you know much modernity
there at all but I thought I thought it
definitely works and I do definitely
want to see more of those that are well
made I agree and mushi she's a good
example like I guess I'm ex because like
it brings in a lot of supernatural
elements as well right yeah so we've
been a paranormal elements but like I
feel like a lot of it is just kind of
like the superstition and beliefs that
people had many years ago it's kind of
creating making that into a story and
they bring that like a reality into the
story yeah yeah so it's almost like
these superstitions that people cause
like things bad luck all that kind of
stuff it comes from the mushi right
these creatures that are exist in the
anime that need to be kind of dealt with
they're just like natural beings they're
not evil or good
they just happens to someone sometimes
they congregate there different they
congregate in one place too much then
stuff starts happening and then being
code the mushi she has to go and solve
that so yeah I think it was a really
well done just like a masterpiece on
anime
uh it was great it really was so what
what genre would you like to see that
you think might be underrated currently
other than historical anime get more
attention in the future from whether
throne Studios to get more funding to
get more cool animes in that genre and I
haven't thought about this either so I'm
gonna have to be thinking about it now
the first thing that comes to mind is
maybe thrillers or more like
psychological but I mean there have been
some that have come out but have not
been good yeah so it's like I think
generally speaking people like those
kind of things but it's just there are
so many bad ones out there that aren't
very thrilling and aren't very exciting
so I would like to see more the last one
that I can think of that was really like
I was there's monster and older ones but
the last one that I really liked was
psycho past like I thought that was very
much a psychological thriller and sci-fi
at the same time yeah
what about horror anime what you get
what are you guys thoughts on that I
don't really watch horror anime i I
guess some some classify like Tokyo
ghoul is horror some classified mushishi
even is horror but I don't really feel
like their horror and I don't watch an
anime and that I would consider like
what is Black Butler or like I don't
know
[Music]
go ahead Matt oh I was just gonna say I
can't really do horror like I just I
can't but I did enjoy another another
was pretty good mm-hmm yeah I need to
walk I mean the show another like
another yeah I had one recommend that to
me like okay make sure man so talk
takeda or tuck it up says that there's
not that many more anime and I think
that's because horror is different in
Japan in here right like here horror is
often like designed basically it's just
to like it's like when you go to a
haunted house like think about what they
do they put you in a dark place and then
they use sudden sounds and like lights
to scare you so what they're trying to
do is elicit come like Fear Factor like
that's what you're trying to do where is
winning yeah it's more psychological so
it's more of a thriller anyway right
like for Japanese for its really
thriller like it's not we're not trying
to scare you like you look all about
we're trying to be like make you think
about old man that's crazy like these
people are messed up or oh man you know
like this superstition could actually be
true and so the song and I got it's more
of a thinking hoard and like how gory
shock you kind of you not die before at
least in my opinion I don't know if you
guys know I completely agree that's why
I brought it up after cuz Brynn
mentioned like thrillers and she wants
like more out of that
like genre and that's something I want
more out of the horror genre yeah I
actually
is there a genre that you haven't tried
yet
or like really given enough tried
haven't tried yeah we yet I'm drunk
thank you the Yahweh King so extremely
popular belief worldwide popular heaven
please widely accepted Canon believe the
absolute truth
at this point it's Canon no it's a thing
hey like how about like vampire shows
yeah anyway anybody watch vampire shows
cuz that's a genre there's how many
people love vampires and stuff but
Twilight kind of ruin vampires for me
yeah
I like Charlie I watch the Vampire
Diaries for a while but just like
ironically with my brother like we would
watch the show under yeah I team Damon
team game moving on no but yeah I feel
like I have seen a lot of
vampire-related anime but I haven't
really been watching that many just
because yeah I kind of like it's been
the last few years maybe like not so
many last few years but in dumb late
2010 it was so much more saturation with
vampires over here in the West they kind
of like I got sick of it um one genre I
haven't really been watching is Sports
anime I haven't watched sports anime in
a while and I hear good things but I'm
not I don't feel motivated to watch them
by like my brother he likes sports anime
he always tells me they're really good
they're motivational so I feel like have
to give more of a chance to Sports anime
oh yeah I see anything for me like I I
took a long time to start watching
sports that maybe I love it now yeah you
gotta find I suggest a personal
suggestion find a sport that you
actually genuinely like before just
picking one like obviously if you've
played that sport it's gonna be more
interesting for like basketball like
we're gonna basket like that's a good
one because you know kind of how it
works and like how the sports supposed
to be so start there and then work your
way out there to the good ones there's a
lot of really good sports and ways out
there yeah I I appreciate your advice
Brenda my brother likes basketball so he
is watching critical right now however
the fact is that I'm literally going to
start watching caged oh oh what a great
thrilling thrilling sports head you can
relate to that word I like a nominee
that I've never played the sport
I did I've never played it but I am a
fan so I'm gonna give it a shot
I yeah I I have to do it because I
watched cyanide blizzard like he was
here last week and I washes over you and
he wanted me actually you thinking like
this is so crazy it just might work
like you know what I think is like what
something is like steam saw just like
high school did that right
it's like this is so crazy that it
actually works yes well get back to us
on how lovely of an anime it was oh well
I'll just take your word for it okay so
then we you're gonna uri a nice Mike a
Joe and I mean it's not I've seen two
episodes of it and it's not a good anime
but if you want to laugh at something
watch gotcha
cuz it's bang hmm yeah was a little bit
like I felt like they were taking it
really see I wanted like a very fun like
it was like so serious exactly up to two
after like two or three episodes yeah no
good Sports anime terms high Q Hajime no
Ippo yeah I haven't seen it but I've
heard a lot of good things and yeah like
I have to watch them but I've heard a
million good things I think I actually
like volleyball and I don't really care
for boxing but I heard Hajime no Ippo is
just so inspirational that I just got
out because my brothers watched all of
it and he he like he gets all like he
wants to box me like randomly you go oh
he's so annoying after Quadros watching
you at the same time and I was like oh
god I just want to smack you and then I
do and then he pulled some Dempsey roll
on you yes that's the name all the time
I don't like what will happen Briggs
when you and my brother meet and then
you both cut Dempsey roll each other
like what will happen the world
you're gonna be like some kind of like
Schrodinger's cat thing happening to any
other genre as anyone else needs to get
into I need to get into sports anime
what else do we have who else said that
means getting to a genre I mean I need
to get into sports anime because I just
don't watch it but I don't really do
sports so I mean but I mean if I have to
watch all the anime ever then I do have
to get it into Sports anime
yeah we do have to watch all anime not
old good anime right no all of it we're
watching literally all the every single
thing that's ever existed me embrace
were just talking today actually about
there are certain people who want to
watch every new animation they can
review and stuff like youtubers or
whatever but like I can't do that I
can't watch every new I don't even
though I know they suck just because
they're new one or popular I think it
might be bother if like I can't do it
like if you enjoy the anime and you like
the concept and then you watch it and
you enjoy it then I by all means but if
like if you're just like I'm gonna do
this as a job like YouTube reviewing an
amazing job it's gonna review every
anime possible so that I can get as much
audience as possible even if I hate it
and I'm like reviewing it but I don't
want to find that it wasn't like this
was so this is amazing interesting
characters I am a Mac loved Yuri on Isis
so much which I mean I'm like saying the
enemy names wrong it's like like yeah I
love the the Yuri's a nice Russian girls
were very brave zero and there was
absolutely no fate it was great love you
Jeff for God has forgotten Queen Oh
chica says the fate series are amazing
we had a couple people thought what the
fate series yeah definitely
a good series definitely an interesting
series and yeah I've seen oh I've seen
quite a bit of it like yeah there are
some parts we're like I feel like the
other character stuff is like their
stool they keep coming back to the whole
conflict though oh I want to save
everyone even if it's impossible it's
like what you're saying makes no sense
like be like Lelouch at least a little
bit man but otherwise I definitely
enjoyed this in the series and the
characters I'm like Alexander degrade
was awesome and fade 0 i I love the fact
they bringing these historical figures
and then make them interesting
fictionalized I love guessing when you
don't know yet who the certain people
are like yeah hero is and then you're
like who is this who is like for DES in
fates stay night on the mat blade works
the magician girl
her name was like Medea or something and
I didn't know who was trying to look it
up and she was like a Greek myth like
goddess like a methodological Greek hero
thing so I thought that was interesting
it's like well I learned something new
like she was like the girlfriend I'm
Jason or something very slow interesting
I guess that's why I like doing like
facts videos and stuff like I find like
little details but like I didn't know
already like so cool like I did a lot of
like reading my watch fate/zero just
like to learn about these people like
Gilgamesh and I'll grandeur the greater
like - my favorite characters in that
series Rider and I mean Archer I guess
you have true Bulls awesome like the
both and I like arturia - I think I was
very interesting how they made King
Arthur a woman yeah you learned that in
like the first episode but no yeah I was
cool because then she she also has like
her own baggage because what and she
tried to also like save her people but
then things happened and yeah very and I
like the twist I saw it coming but the
twist and unlimited blade works I saw it
coming so I was like super hyped and my
brother didn't so and I told woman again
and I was like yes I told you but yeah I
thought that was interesting
I'm not gonna get into almost boil it
for you guys but it was cool
I know you're talking about that took me
way too long I figured out my bad
I think they so huge like a huge part of
that show I did not realize what you
were talking about someone asked is
there a general release date for the new
Code Geass I think someone sent at the
end of next year that they were aiming
for that however I'm not a hundreds
insurer I'm gonna try to get all the
facts I can in the next few weeks about
the new Code Geass equal the movies that
are coming out that bridge movies and
that kind of stuff and then probably put
out a video on that kind of catching us
up with all the facts because the thing
is it's hard to know the facts first of
all they change second of all people
spread rumors that are not actually true
and third of all the translation issue
so that you have to get people to
translate it from the Japanese and
Austin that's very unreliable so you
have so little okay I'll do looking into
and subs are scary place yeah the names
of someone yeah the names of some of the
subbing people defense of those those
make me laugh for days if I like like
you said like false information it could
happen so easily with like translations
like yesterday so can each of my aside
with my favorite anime and the Creator
actually followed me on twitter which is
blessed and he created something I have
to translate his tweets because they're
all in Japanese mm-hmm and so I
translate them and it was something but
like new episodes I'm like what new
episodes but like it was just like he
was just talking about like his DVD set
or something or like I don't even know
what it was but I saw all I saw was new
episode that's the only thing that
translated nicely and I was getting
height for no reason by the way
everybody on Saturday at 12 p.m. so noon
eastern standard time we're gonna be
doing a special live stream on Code
Geass theories so theories are all about
Code Geass here on an anime uproar so
come join us and that I'm whatever we're
gonna do is Briggs is gonna be their
brand by the way if you you think oh yes
right you've seen everything No
okay nevermind I thought you did but
Rose didn't finish it
something but alright so what we're
gonna be doing is we're going to have a
live chat talking about all the
different theories about code geass
season 3 and so on and then I'm going to
take notes and find the best theories
that we come up with I'm having like a
video like the best theories about code
geass season 3 and the rest of Korea so
definitely be there if you can make it
on Saturday 12:00 noon Eastern Standard
Time this same warrior time same or your
channel is this but yes that's gonna be
fun did you guys want to talk about
anything else any other genre latest
stuff or should we get ready to wrap it
up there um Emilia versus Ram let's go
I'm just gonna wait for the video I'm
gonna expose the truth expose it all day
if you want to be with me maybe look old
collab on it or something it's gonna be
it she's gonna be it it's gonna get more
dislikes than the Ghostbusters trailer
oh really
trailer whoever it's gonna be worth it
and Mac I'm gonna need your leafy
impersonation skills if you will I would
like to do a leaf we'll be in touch
we'll be I did I need to hear this like
maybe not now
well I will okay and by the way by the
way we're next ran cafe next week is
going to be about kind of looking at the
best and worst of 2016 when it comes to
anime and also looking a bit ahead at
the next seasons and upcoming stuff Liu
talks anime is gonna be joining us for
the first time he's gonna be our new
guest next rank of face so don't miss
that and all you guys are invited back
as well I don't know if everybody can
make it but let me know if you can and
hopefully Rose can come back as well
because we haven't had her on forever
because she's busy with non anime stuff
like what
well not anime stuff yes it's like that
muggle stuff muggle studies yeah yeah so
I think we cannot start wrapping it up
now thanks everybody for coming everyone
in the chat we had a great time at
another great chat again it's hard to
even keep up with older messages coming
in and out which is awesome that's
exactly what we want what all you guys
to take me participating and driving the
discussion and helping yourself let's do
the whole what we are and what we do
kind of thing again let's start with
Bryn ladies first
I am a human that is what I am what I do
I am one of you I am woman hear me roar
start coming out Oh
like some are you're sick yes that is me
human but I am Bryn from prints fandoms
and I - anime discussions and
spoiler-free discussions and spoiler
filled ones depending on the day but I'm
here on the YouTube and the Twitter is
mostly where I am and it's all at prints
fandoms so if you want to follow along
and subscribe that's where you can find
me and by the way the links to all of
the channels brand Mac and called
animate are in the description if you
want to check them out of course there
are awesome people and we have an
awesome community here at rant cafe I
feel like feel like we're really
building a great community I love it I
love it I love every day every week
spending time with you guys might
YouTube funny lovely everyone chat like
such a pleasure Briggs let's go to you
who you are
what do you do I am Briggs from all the
anime I make like like top FAQ videos
like fun facts things you wouldn't
already know about certain characters in
series like I said in the stream like I
don't know I'm very interested in
knowing details about stuff like I'll go
online
full-on research rats that like learn
about Gilgamesh from fate/zero and stuff
like that I've been recently
implementing like some facecam because I
want people like kind of get to know me
so I did like a quiz for my last video
so uh yeah that's kind of what I do I
also have a Twitter that's where you can
find me as well yeah actually I feel
left out the Mac man tell us about
yourself who you are what you do well
let me tell you a thing I'm Mac I'm on
the youtubes is Michael nut I'm mostly
on twitch I guess I do a lot of like
skits stuff and a lot of yeah just like
just kind of kind of whatever I feel
like but it's mostly Skid stuff and
there's no content until the new year on
my youtube channel but which is a thing
so you can you can find me there and we
can hang out and do the stuff and the
things and yeah what about the Q&A oh no
okay that's it that's I mean that's not
content but sounds good and yes filler
content is still content filler content
is still content yeah you can find Mack
on Twitch eat twitch stream several
times a week is really
is really awesome and yeah once again I
just want to thank everybody for coming
to these chats regularly now this is our
fifth episode already and in every chat
we've had so many people talking and
raising all these awesome issues we've
never had a situation where like no
one's talking in the chat where we're on
our own which is amazing we're building
a really cool community here I love it I
love it every week I look forward to it
I appreciate everybody who comes
whenever you can make it we'd love to
have you thank you my awesome youtube
friends for being our special guests
means a lot to me definitely check out
these guys they're awesome and yeah we
can call it a day again thank you
everybody and until next time see you
space Cowboys
bang